say you're helping plan a friend's party
and he sends you a text asking you to
bring Bob a DJ and a clown you're pretty
impressed you had no idea bob was so
multi-talented but when the day arrives
it turns out that he's not and you were
supposed to bring three different people
as you and Bob sit at the silent clown
'less party it occurs to you that the
confusion could have been avoided simply
by using another comma after DJ this
final comma in a list placed directly
before the main conjunction such as and
or or nor is called the serial comma or
Oxford comma and it has long driven
grammar nerds crazy because even major
language institutions can't agree on
whether it should be used ironically the
Oxford comma is more common in the
United States where it's recommended by
the MLA the Chicago style manual and the
US Government Printing Office though not
by the AP Stylebook in the UK and other
english-speaking countries most style
guides do not support the commas use
with the exception of its namesake the
oxford university press why not use the
serial comma one of the main arguments
is that the conjunction is usually
enough to denote a separate entity and
where it's not like in your ill-fated
invite list changing the order of terms
will usually do the job journalists also
dislike the comma because it takes up
precious space and can make text look
cluttered sometimes it can even create
confusion of its own for example if your
friend had asked for Bob a DJ and a
puppy you'd probably figure out that
there are three separate beings puppies
are cute but they don't make great djs
with the comma you may think bob is the
DJ and all you need is him and the puppy
the argument over the Oxford comma has
raised such strong passions over the
years that a sort of truce has been
reached the common wisdom is that its
use is optional and depends on whether
it will help to avoid confusion for one
thing you're supposed to keep your use
or avoidance of the Oxford comma
consistent throughout a whole piece of
writing so using it only where necessary
is not an option and the very idea of a
grammatical rule being optional is a bit
odd imagine that you hadn't messed up
the
ready planning and read the next day
that everyone had a great time ninjas
pirates Vikings old and young if the
Oxford comma were standard you would
notice it missing and conclude that old
and young must describe the awesome
guests already listed but as things
stand you will always wonder whether it
means that a bunch of regular boring
kids and old people showed up as well
ultimately the serial comma may be
useful or annoying but your opinion on
it as for many optional things probably
has something to do with whichever style
you were raised on your high school
teachers favored it it's likely you're
still using it your first editor hated
it you probably do too and maybe so much
hair-splitting over a tie nice wiggle on
a page is a bit silly after all there
are so many bigger problems to worry
about but sometimes little things can
make a big difference
you